en efecto está en curso una
investigación en verdad dos
investigaciones una de ellas por parte
del llamado servicio civil es decir la
burocracia interna
a la administración
británica
no se espera que ese reporte que
seguramente saldrá en las próximas dos
semanas se convierta en una suerte de
bala de plata fatal en contra del primer
ministro la otra investigación la que
llevaría a cabo la policía
puede ser más dañina pero de nuevo no se
espera que sea suficiente para causar la
salida del primer ministro más bien es
la masiva pérdida de apoyo popular la
que podría causar el que quienes aún le
apoyan dentro de su propio partido
retiren ese apoyo ya hemos escuchado
voces en ese sentido y si esas voces
alcanzan
el número de votos necesarios al menos
unas 50 cartas de parte de miembros del
parlamento del partido de gobierno
solamente en ese caso tendría lugar la
posibilidad de una moción de censura
contra el primer ministro